bon l'actualité judiciaire marqué par la
condamnation à dix ans de réclusion
criminelle pour l'abbé morale la cour
d'assises de l'aveyron a été moins
sévère que l'avocat général qui
demandait 12 ans de réclusion les jurés
ont reconnu l'accusé coupable de viols
sur deux de ses anciens élèves dominique
verdeilhan et blaise grenier à l'énoncé
du verdict l'abbé morel n'a pas réagi il
a simplement fermer les yeux quand ils
quittent le palais de justice de rodez
ils essuient les insultes de
quelques-uns de ses opposants un peu
plus loin
le maire du village exprime son soutien
à l'une des victimes je suis un peu ému
je trouve pas trop les mots mais ce que
j'attendais depuis longtemps que qu'ils
soient jugés coupables mais ce que
j'attendais depuis longtemps puisque je
savais que tu étais coupable et enfin la
justice l'a su le reconnaissent
jean-lucien morel a été acquitté pour le
viol de françois mais condamné pour ceux
de florent et kevin pour la mère de ce
dernier
ce verdict aidera peut-être d'autres
adolescents a parlé je pense que
d'autres personnes d'autres victimes
auront sans doute le courage de faire
comme nos de dénoncer ces faits même
soulagement
même satisfaction du côté des anciens
élèves du collège pour qui les faits
étaient prescrits
vous avez craint l'équipement un peu
j'avais peur que oui effectivement ça
m'est arrivé de craindre l'acquittement
et la lisant ça vous soulage
c'est pas la durée de la peine qui me
soulage c'est le fait qu'il était
reconnu coupable
après la peine je crois qu'il ya pas de
peine qui soit qu'ils soient justes pour
de tels actes
on attend le verdict pour faire une
déclaration ne veux pas anticiper sur un
avenir aux quarts les avocats seront
nettement moins bavard est beaucoup plus
discret après la condamnation de leurs
clients j'ai plaidé l'acquittement ces
dix ans et c'est une déception
effectivement mais nous aviserons pour
pour l'avenir ce matin l'ancienne ferme
auberge a retrouvé le calme et la
sérénité d'un palais de justice de
campagne